Oh
hi, ich bin Peter Robinson und willkommen zu
Denkerinnen in der Antike im
Mittelalter, einer
Vortragsreihe des King's College London und der LMU
München. Dies ist eine
Gemeinschaftsproduktion dieser beiden Universitäten, für die ich
früher am King's College London unterrichtet habe
12 Jahre und ich bin immer noch dem
dortigen Fachbereich Philosophie verbunden und bin
Professorin für spätantike und arabische
Philosophie hier an der LMU in München in
dieser Vorlesungsreihe, wie der Titel schon
sagt, werden wir uns mit
Denkerinnen der klassischen Antike befassen
bis zum Ende des
Mittelalters, ungefähr der Beginn der
Renaissance, wird Christine
de Pizan behandelt, sie wird die neueste Denkerin sein, die
wir behandeln werden, und wir werden
nicht nur fragen, wer die wichtigsten
Denkerinnen in der Antike waren  im Mittelalter, sondern
auch, was männliche Denker gewissermaßen über Philosophinnen zu sagen hatten,
dies ist ein
sehr aktuelles Thema für viele Historiker
der Philosophie und Geistesgeschichte
allgemeiner mor  Wir
interessieren uns im Allgemeinen sehr für Denkerinnen und
Intellektuelle in verschiedenen Kulturen, und
wir werden uns tatsächlich
auch einige andere Kulturen ansehen. Wenn ich
also die klassische Antike sage, denken Sie wahrscheinlich
an das antike Griechenland,
und dorthin werden wir gehen  Beginnen wir heute, aber
wir werden uns auch das
alte Indien ansehen und sehen, was
Denkerinnen zur
Philosophie in der indischen Kultur beigetragen haben könnten, aber normalerweise
denken die Leute, wenn sie an Frauen in der
Geschichte der Philosophie denken, nicht an die
Antike oder das Mittelalter und
Das ist aus dem sehr guten Grund, dass die
meisten Leute glauben, dass es
in der latenten oder früheren
antiken Kultur oder im Mittelalter keine Philosophinnen gegeben hat,
sie denken sicherlich nicht an
Denkerinnen und wenn sie an das
alte Indien denken und wenn Menschen denken
Wenn es überhaupt um Philosophinnen
geht, werden sie wahrscheinlich
einige Philosophen der
frühen Neuzeit im Sinn haben, und ich werde etwas sagen
Aber dazu später, aber ich denke, es
gibt heutzutage eine Art Konsens darüber,
dass es ein interessantes und lohnendes
Projekt ist, sich mit Denkerinnen,
Philosophinnen in welcher Zeit auch
immer zu befassen, und so wird das Projekt
dieser Vortragsreihe wirklich
sein  sehen, ob wir dieses
Projekt, das derzeit
mit ziemlich viel Energie verfolgt wird, auf die
frühe Neuzeit,
insbesondere auf das frühneuzeitliche Europa,
anwenden können, ob wir dieses Projekt auf die
antike Welt, die spätantike Welt und die
mittelalterliche Welt anwenden können  Bevor ich auf die
Vor- und Nachteile eingehe, lassen Sie
mich noch etwas zum Titel sagen,
also dachte ich darüber nach, diese
Philosophinnen in der Antike und
im Mittelalter oder so zu nennen, aber
am Ende entschied ich mich dafür  Gehen Sie mit
den allgemeineren und
unverbindlicheren Denkern, und ein Grund, warum ich das
getan habe, ist, weil ich
irgendwelchen Einwänden zuvorkommen oder eine
Debatte offen lassen wollte  herauszufinden, ob alle
Denker tatsächlich
Philosophen waren, also bin ich
Philosophiehistoriker, ich habe auch eine sehr breite
Vorstellung davon, was als Philosophie gilt, und
gemäß meiner Vorstellung davon, was
Philosophie ist, kann es Personen einschließen, die es
sind  oft als Mystikerin beschrieben, um zum
Beispiel nur die berühmteste Person zu nehmen, die
wir uns ansehen werden, die
in diese Kategorie fallen könnte Hildegard
von Bingen, eine mittelalterliche Denkerin des 12. Jahrhunderts,
wird oft
eher als Mystikerin als als Philosophin beschrieben
das wir uns vielleicht tatsächlich
ansehen werden, wird einige
weibliche Sufis aus der islamischen Welt und
auch einige Figuren aus dem 14
von ihnen,
aber sie sind keine Philosophen und
vielleicht sind sie nicht einmal Figuren,
die der Historiker der
Philosophie ernst nehmen sollte, also gibt es hier eine große
Frage  Ob Mystik
Teil der Geschichte der Philosophie ist und
auch ob andere Menschen, die möglicherweise
auf andere Weise zur intellektuellen Aktivität beigetragen haben,
ein Beispiel aus der
islamischen Kultur wären, die
Berichte über den Propheten gesammelt haben, also
gibt es etwas anderes,
aber kurz später  Daher gibt es
viele Fragen darüber, ob Figuren
, die sich mit diesen anderen
intellektuellen Aktivitäten befassen, für die Astronomenphilosophie von Interesse sind
, da ich, wie ich sage
, eine sehr breite Vorstellung davon habe, was
die Geschichte oder Philosophie beinhalten könnte
und beinhalten sollte, und so habe ich '
Ich bin ziemlich glücklich, irgendeine der Figuren, die
wir in dieser
Vortragsreihe behandeln werden, Philosophen zu nennen, die Sie vielleicht
nicht sind, und wir werden sehen, dass
es vielleicht eine Debatte über
einige der Figuren geben wird und ob sie es sind
Philosophen hin oder her und deshalb heißt diese
Serie
Denkerinnen statt Philosophinnen, okay, also sag nicht nur
was dazu  Projekt als
Ganzes nicht so sehr das Projekt,
Philosophen zu betrachten, die in der
Antike und im Mittelalter weiblich waren, sondern wirklich
die ganze Idee, sich auf
Philosophinnen in jeder Epoche zu konzentrieren, so denke ich,
das erste und offensichtlichste
Argument dafür  Das ist,
dass viele Leute nicht wissen, dass
es in diesen Perioden Philosophinnen gab,
also ob es das frühneuzeitliche Europa, das
alte Indien, die islamische Kultur, die
antike Welt in Griechenland und Rom ist,
was
ist ein offensichtlicher Grund, dieses Projekt zu machen
soll nur auf die Tatsache aufmerksam machen,
dass diese Leute existierten, und ich werde jetzt
eine Folie hochwerfen, die Ihnen eine
Liste von Persönlichkeiten aus der antiken Welt zeigt, auf die
wir später noch zu einer Liste von Personen
aus der mittelalterlichen Welt kommen, die wir  werden
abdecken, und wie Sie dieser Liste entnehmen können,
gibt es eine ganze Reihe von Persönlichkeiten
, die zumindest im weitesten Sinne als Philosophen gelten
und die
in der Antike gearbeitet oder gelebt haben, also
fangen wir heute an  Aktu  lly, indem Sie
sich einige der Vornamen auf
der Liste Theon und Melissa ansehen, und so
viel zu mr.  Ton, äh, aber
erstens sind sie alle Pythagoräer, die Frauen sind
und deren Werke vielleicht noch vorhanden sind, oder
wenn wir gleich darüber sprechen, dann
gehen wir zum fünften und vierten
Jahrhundert v. Chr. über, wir haben den Gottheitsmann
Aspasia, der ziemlich viel sagen wird
ungefähr in diesem Vortrag später dann habe
ich im dritten zweiten Jahrhundert v. Chr.
drei Figuren aus der indischen Tradition gesetzt
, auf die man sich einlassen würde, und
dann können Sie eine Liste späterer antiker
Denker sehen, die ich in einem
weiteren Vortrag behandeln werde  Wenn Sie sich also diese
Folie ansehen, werden Sie sehen, dass wir
im sechsten Jahrhundert v. Chr. mit mehreren
Figuren beginnen, von denen Sie wahrscheinlich noch nie gehört haben,
tatsächlich haben Sie wahrscheinlich noch nie von
jemandem auf dieser Liste gehört, außer vielleicht haben Sie
von Gottheiten gehört  mo, die eine Figur ist
, kommt in Plato vor, vielleicht haben Sie von
ihrer Leidenschaft für 15 gehört, Sie werden sie
unten auf der Folie sehen, aber heute
werden wir nur über drei
dieser Figuren aus dem 6. Jahrhundert
v  Pythagoräer Theano Mia und Melissa
Ich werde do tema kurz erwähnen, aber
ich werde hauptsächlich über den
Spazio sprechen, der eine Figur ist, die eigentlich eine reale
Person ist, aber auch eine Figur, die
in Plato vorkommt, und Sie können sehen, dass dort auch
einige indische Denker sind, die ich habe
unten als  Vom 3. bis zum 2.
Jahrhundert v. Chr. zu leben, obwohl
es sehr schwer zu sagen ist, wann ein Denker aus dem alten Indien tatsächlich gelebt hat
, ok, das ist der erste
Grund, warum wir
Denkerinnen in der Antike studieren sollten, und allgemeiner gesagt,
es gab einige und als Historiker
sollten wir es tun  Die Aufgabe genommen zu haben
, alles zu studieren, was existiert hat, aber das
ist natürlich ein ziemlich schwacher Grund. Ich meine,
Sie könnten argumentieren, dass wir Steuerbescheiddokumente aus der Antike studieren sollten,
weil wir einige
Steuerbescheiddokumente übrig haben, ist ein sehr starker
Grund, daran interessiert zu sein  Es
gibt also einen besonderen Grund, warum wir
Denkerinnen aus der Antike
im Mittelalter verfolgen sollten. Ich denke, ein
offensichtlicher Grund ist, dass, wenn Sie
die Idee von ap heraufbeschwören  Philosoph in Ihrem Kopf
oder ein Denker, um das allgemeinere
Wort zu verwenden, dann stellen Sie sich wahrscheinlich
jemanden vor, der ein bisschen wie ich aussieht, also stellen
Sie sich
vielleicht sogar einen glatzköpfigen Fan vor,
und Sie stellen sich wahrscheinlich sogar einen Mann
mit vor  ein Bart in meinem Fall von Bier, der
weiß zu werden beginnt und der
auch halten würde, wenn Sie anfangen, sich
über bestimmte Namen zu treffen, also wer ein
Philosoph ist, der ein wichtiger Denker ist, werden
Sie wahrscheinlich an
Sokrates Plato und Aristoteles
aus der Antike denken  Mittelalter, Sie denken vielleicht
an Agustin, eigentlich ist er
wirklich spät dran, ich unterrichte, aber machen wir uns keine
Sorgen, jetzt denken Sie an Thomas von
Aquin, vielleicht denken Sie später an
den Schwanzkarren von Live Nets Kant, zu dem Sie nicht gehen  an
Frauen zu denken, und das ist tatsächlich ein Problem
, es sind vielleicht mehrere Probleme.
Erstens ist es richtig, weil wir
bereits gesehen haben, dass es weibliche Denker gab,
aber zweitens bedeutet es, dass
Frauen heutzutage das fühlen könnten  Ihnen
fehlen Vorbilder und sie denken vielleicht sogar
, dass Philosophie etwas ist, was
Männer tun und nicht etwas, was Frauen tun,
so dass die Idee, dass Philosophen in der
Vergangenheit und vielleicht sogar in der
Gegenwart Männer waren, vielleicht sogar Männer, um so auszusehen wie ich,
wie ich sage, zu sein könnte  Frauen die Vorstellung,
dass sie keine Philosophen sein können, und
könnten Männern die Vorstellung vermitteln, dass
Frauen keine Philosophen sein können, so dass
einerseits Frauen keine Vorbilder sind,
andererseits Frauen und Männer eine Art
sexistische Annahme darüber haben, wer
Philosoph sein kann und wer  nicht, es gibt hier auch
eine Frage der Gerechtigkeit, wenn Sie also daran
denken, dass die Hälfte der Menschen,
die jemals gelebt haben, Frauen waren, scheint es
sehr unwahrscheinlich, dass keiner von ihnen irgendwelche
philosophischen Ideen hatte, und in der Tat
, wie wir sehen werden  in dieser
Vortragsreihe hatten viele von ihnen
philosophische Ideen, die Tatsache, dass wir
nichts über sie wissen, scheint
eine Art Gerechtigkeit darzustellen, man könnte sogar sagen,
dass diese Frauen von seiner zum Schweigen gebracht wurden
Leider wurden ihre Werke nicht aufbewahrt,
sie wurden nicht kopiert und sie wurden
von Männern vielleicht nicht sehr viel diskutiert, und
daher ist das Projekt, sie in einer
Vortragsreihe wie dieser zu betrachten, eine Art zu
schreiben oder falsch als eine Art von D
Schweigen also, das ist meiner Meinung nach eigentlich
ein guter Grund, das zu tun, was ich
in dieser Serie vorhabe, ein weiterer
Grund, der meiner Meinung nach in gewisser Weise
etwas spekulativer, aber eigentlich
ziemlich interessant ist und
relevant werden wird  Bereits in dieser ersten
Vorlesung werden wir sehen, dass einige Leute
sagen würden, dass
die Art und Weise
, wie viel Philosophie gemacht wird, etwas ausgesprochen Männliches an sich hat,
wenn man sich nur vorstellt, was in
modernen Philosophieabteilungen wie
Walk in the Philosophie untergeht  Abteilung
zu einem Vortrag in die Vereinigten Staaten oder das Vereinigte Königreich
oder sogar nach Kontinentaleuropa gehen, und was
Sie sehen werden, ist eine oft sehr intensive
Debatte, und oft wird die Debatte
eine Menge Macho-Gehabe beinhalten, und einige Leute
haben es getan  war kritisch und sagte, dass ein
Teil des Grundes, warum wir
mehr Frauen in der Philosophie haben sollten, darin besteht, dass
dies sogar eine sehr schlechte Art sein
könnte, eine Philosophie zu betreiben
schnelle Gegeneinwände und
Abstriche vielleicht sollten wir uns die
Philosophie als ein kooperativeres
Unternehmen vorstellen, manche Leute würden das darauf zurückführen
, dass es nicht genug Frauen
in der Philosophie gibt und allgemeiner
könnten wir sagen, dass es die Philosophie in der gesamten Geschichte der
Philosophie gegeben hat  war oft eine
Art von Männern dominiertes Unternehmen, und
hier gäbe es kein besseres Beispiel
als das Mittelalter, auf das
wir später noch eingehen werden, also denken Sie
darüber nach, wie die Philosophie
im Mittelalter hauptsächlich betrieben wurde
und wie  Die Philosophie wurde ausschließlich
gemacht, wenn man sich die meisten Philosophiegeschichten ansieht,
die nur die scholastische Philosophie berücksichtigen.
Philosophie wurde
an der mittelalterlichen Universität gemacht  sität,
was nur von Männern bedeutete, weil
Frauen an der mittelalterlichen Universität nicht studieren oder lehren durften
und
es sehr viel durch Disputation geschah,
also hatte man einen Meister,
der einen Disput mit Studenten beaufsichtigte,
und es würde Einwände geben
Gegeneinwände wären sehr konfrontativ,
es wäre irgendwie kämpferisch, und
das geht tatsächlich bis zum
Ende zurück,
wenn wir Play-Doh haben und insbesondere eine
horizontale Erforschung der Idee, dass
Argumentationstechniken und Techniken der
Widerlegung eine gute Möglichkeit sein könnten
Philosophie, das ist es, was Aristoteles
Dialektik nennt, und wieder finden sich
feministische Philosophiehistoriker oder
Ideenhistoriker allgemeiner, die
argumentieren, dass dies eine Art
prototypischer und charakterlich treffender
männlicher Art sei, Philosophie zu betreiben, und
dass, wenn wir Philosophie als
Wesen betrachten wollen  auf andere Weise getan
, wenn Sie sich Werke von Frauen ansehen könnten, wenn Sie also
jemanden wie Hildegard von
Bingen oder Mugabe Poe ernst nehmen  Es ist ein anderer mittelalterlicher
Denker, auf den wir später noch eingehen werden.
Wenn Sie diese Frauen
ernst nehmen, wie sie
Philosophie schreiben, sehen Sie vielleicht eine
Art alternative Art,
Philosophie zu betreiben, vielleicht denken Sie sogar,
dass es bestimmte philosophische
Ideen gibt  die
eher von Frauen als von Männern zum Ausdruck gebracht werden, und wenn das
stimmt, wenn es eine ausgesprochen
weibliche Art zu philosophieren gibt, die
Sie eher bei
Frauen finden, dann finden Sie sie natürlich auch bei Männern,
aber wenn es eine Möglichkeit gibt
Philosophie zu betreiben ist mehr charakteristisch
für Frauen als für Männer, dann würden wir durch das
Ignorieren weiblicher Denker in der Geschichte
der Philosophie natürlich
diese ganze Art von Philosophie ignorieren.
Ich möchte nicht
unbedingt sagen, dass ich dieser Idee zustimme
Es gibt eine Art männliche Art
, Philosophie zu betreiben, und eine weibliche Art
, Philosophie zu betreiben. Es ist ziemlich offensichtlich,
dass diese Art des Denkens
viele der sexistischen Annahmen übernehmen könnte  dass wir gerade
gesagt haben, dass wir versuchen zu bekämpfen,
indem wir in erster Linie auf Frauen in der Geschichte oder Philosophie achten,
aber
etwas, das ich betonen
und in der Tat in diesem
allerersten Vortrag heute ansprechen möchte, ist das in der früheren
Geschichte, wenn er neu erschaffen wurde  In seinen
Geschichtsperioden ging man sehr stark
davon aus, dass Frauen, denen es erlaubt war
, über Philosophie zu sprechen,
über bestimmte Themen und nicht über andere
Themen sprechen und eher bestimmte Dinge
als andere Dinge sagen würden, oder sie hätten vielleicht,
dass es einige Tugenden gibt, die
charakteristisch dazu gehören  Frauen, und wenn
wir zu Frauen gehen, die Ehefrauen sind, die philosophisch sind,
dann sollten wir zu
ihnen genau um Einsichten in
diese Art von weiblichen Themen oder weiblichen
Tugenden gehen, und
darauf werden wir später noch eingehen  In diesem
Vortrag möchte ich
noch einen weiteren Grund dafür nennen,
Frauen in der Geschichte der Philosophie zu studieren,
dass, wie ich bereits sagte, einige der
Figuren es waren  wird abdecken, und
das gilt übrigens eher für die Antike und das
Mittelalter als für die Frühe
Neuzeit, aber ganz
allgemein, wenn Sie sich in diese
Wahrheitsphilosophie vertiefen und nach weiblichen
Figuren suchen, dann werden Sie fündig  viel
mehr, wenn Sie bereit sind, einen breiten
Ansatz
zu verfolgen,
d
Philosoph, dann werden Sie in der Lage sein
, mehr Frauenfiguren in
Ihre Geschichte der Philosophie aufzunehmen, und
zufälligerweise wollte ich das sowieso tun,
damit einige Zuschauer vielleicht wissen, dass ich
tatsächlich eine Podcast-Serie mit
dem Titel History of Philosophy Podcast und in habe
Eine Art und Weise, daran zu arbeiten, hat mich dazu gebracht,
mich so für dieses Thema zu interessieren, weil
ich versuche, wie das Motto des
Podcasts sagt, die Geschichte der
Philosophie lückenlos abzudecken, was bedeutet,
dass ich versuche, nicht nur die Geschichte der Philosophie abzudecken
große Persönlichkeiten und die Kulturen, die
wir alle kennen, aber auch die
sogenannte Nebenfiguren-Philosophie und
die islamische Welt in Indien, Afrika und
so weiter,
und
währenddessen habe ich mich sehr
für die Idee interessiert
Hervorheben des Beitrags von
Denkerinnen sowie von Denkern, so dass ich
schon aus anderen Gründen
nicht nur
Denkerinnen, sondern eigentlich Mystiker im
Allgemeinen als Teil dieses lückenlosen
Ansatzes der Geschichte der Philosophie einbeziehen wollte, bei dem
ich alles in
Betracht ziehe Ich schaue auf andere Kulturen  schau dir die
wissenschaften an ich schaue mir die mystik an du nennst es im
grunde wenn es so meine faustregel ist
wenn du im zweifel bist ob
etwas für dich als philosophiehistoriker interessant ist oder nicht solltest
du einfach
davon ausgehen dass es von
interesse ist  Für Sie also sollten Sie eher nach
Dingen suchen, die Sie einbeziehen, als nach Dingen
, die Sie ausschließen möchten, und es passiert einfach so, dass
ich deshalb diese Art von zwei Dingen
sowieso tun wollte,
dh  einschließlich Figuren, die vielleicht
marginal sind, ob sie
als Philosophen wie Mystiker kommen, und
einschließlich weiblicher Denker, sie gehen Hand in
Hand, und das ist für mich persönlich ein
weiterer Grund, warum ich mich für
dieses Projekt interessiere, also gibt es viele
Gründe, warum wir es tun sollten  Ich möchte dies tun,
bevor ich loslege und es tue. Ich
möchte nur ein paar Dinge darüber sagen, warum wir
vielleicht nervös sind, es trotzdem zu tun,
und der erste Grund ist dieser so eine
Grund, warum Sie vielleicht nervös sind
oder zögern, sich darauf einzulassen
Eine Reise mit mir
ist, wenn Sie darüber nachdenken, was wir
normalerweise in der Geschichtsphilosophie tun, seien
wir ehrlich, wir studieren normalerweise Männer und
wir studieren berühmte männliche Philosophen nicht
als Männer, also denken wir nicht an Plato
Aristoteles Platonists, den Gründer von
Euphemismus und Spätantike
als Mann und studiere sie nicht als solche,
und so könntest du denken, dass es irgendwie
seltsam und sogar illegitim ist, zu studieren
, sagen wir, Macrina, es war eine spätantike
Philosophin oder Gottheit, ma if sh  e existierte
wieder Ich werde später heute etwas über sie sagen
Es könnte
etwas Seltsames oder Illegales daran sein
, sie als Frauen zu sehen, als ob dies
automatisch das
Wichtigste an ihnen sein würde. Ich
meine, ich würde das als eine  Art von
sexistischer Annahme, also stell dir vor, du
triffst jemanden, der sagt etwas und du
denkst gut, das Wichtigste, was ich
bedenken muss, wenn diese Person mir sagt
, was sie denkt, ist, dass sie eine Frau ist,
ich meine, selbst wenn du dachtest, sie ist eine
Frau  Ich sollte ihr also glauben, dass das
immer noch etwas Seltsames und
Wesentliches ist
, und Sie könnten denken, dass
wir eigentlich
Frauen in unsere Philosophiegeschichte integrieren sollten,
so wie wir weitermachen, und genau
das tue ich in der Podcast-
Serie  Also gehe ich chronologisch vor
und als ich im 12. Jahrhundert zur Höllengarde-Meinung kam, habe
ich Hildegard von Bingen gecovert und bin
dann weitergegangen, damit ich keine besondere
Folge von Folgen hatte  Isoden nur über Frauen, wie
wir es in dieser Vorlesungsreihe tun. Ein
weiteres Problem, das in gewisser Weise
sogar fast das gleiche Problem ist, ist, dass wir am
Ende einen Großteil des historischen Kontexts ignorieren
, der uns helfen wird,
die einzelnen Frauen so zu verstehen  Nochmals, um das
Beispiel von Hildegards Meinung zu verwenden, sie
lebt im 12. Jahrhundert, sie ist eine Nonne,
also schreibt sie in einer buchstäblich
klösterlichen Umgebung, und das ist
wirklich wichtig für das Verständnis ihrer
Arbeit. Außerdem ist es wichtig zu wissen, wie andere
Menschen auf sie reagieren und auch,
was männlich ist  Denker ungefähr
zur gleichen Zeit taten, und tatsächlich wäre es für alle
weiblichen Mystiker, die
wir später im Mittelalter behandeln
werden, meiner Meinung nach ein schwerer Fehler,
sie zu studieren, ohne zumindest darauf hinzuweisen
, dass es dort gibt  waren männliche Mystiker,
die mit ihnen zeitgleich waren und
oft sehr ähnliche Werke schrieben. Ein weiteres
Problem, das hier auftaucht, ist, dass es eine
Gefahr gibt, wenn wir sozusagen
nach den Frauen suchen a  nn in der Geschichte
der Philosophie besteht die Gefahr, dass
Beweise übertrieben werden, weil wir
so sehr daran interessiert sind, Denkerinnen zu finden und
ihre Arbeit irgendwie hervorzuheben, dass wir
Texte nehmen, die nicht einmal wirklich von
Frauen stammen, und davon ausgehen, dass sie von ihnen stammen  Frauen
Wir könnten Texte nehmen, in denen Frauen
so behandelt werden, als ob Frauen wirklich
das Hauptinteresse dieser Texte wären, wenn
der Autor des Textes eigentlich nur
über Frauen sprach und irgendwie
unwichtig vorbeiging, so dass die Gefahr einer
Art von besteht  Dass die Beweise manchmal aufgebläht werden
und dann besonders, werden
wir sicherlich heute in dieser ersten
Vorlesung sehen, wenn wir uns alte Texte ansehen,
stellt sich heraus, dass es keine alten
philosophischen Texte gibt, die von Frauen geschrieben wurden,
tatsächlich gibt es kaum Texte, die
von Frauen geschrieben wurden  alles, um von der Antike an zu überleben,
und hier meine ich mit Antike
bis in die Spätantike und in die byzantinische Zeit, also wenn wir
Werke lesen, die sich mit Frauen und von
Frauen in der se befassen  Da sie
für uns die Vorstellungen von Frauen repräsentieren, stellt sich heraus,
dass wir normalerweise
Werke von Männern lesen, in denen sie uns erzählen, was
eine Frau gesagt hat, also wäre ein großartiges Beispiel
hier meine Carina, die
später leben wird  Sie ist die Schwester eines griechischen
Kirchenvaters namens Gregor von Nyssa und
Gregor hat ein Werk geschrieben, eigentlich zwei Werke
über sie, in einem davon wird sie
auf ihrem Sterbebett als eine Art
Sokrates-Figur dargestellt und sie spricht über
die Unsterblichkeit der Seele und später  Auf
Ich werde über Macrinus-
Theorien der Seele sprechen und ich werde
diese Arbeit als Beweis für Macrina
als Denker verwenden, aber eines der Dinge, denen wir uns stellen
müssen, wenn wir das tun,
ist das  ist nicht das Werk, das
buchstäblich von einer Okarina niedergeschrieben oder
sogar von Macrina Gregory diktiert wurde
, oder um es zuzuschreiben, wurde es
von Gregor, ihrem Bruder, geschrieben, und das
Gleiche gilt für
viele der Werke, die wir uns ansehen werden  aus der
antiken Welt  in der Tat vielleicht sogar
alle Werke, also ist einer der Texte, über die
ich heute sprechen werde, ein Dialog
von Platon, in dem eine Hauptfigur
Aspasia vorkommt, und ich werde über sie sprechen
und warum Platon
sie so dargestellt hat  das hat er getan, und mein Punkt ist
, dass wir hier
über Platons Absicht
als Autor nachdenken müssen und nicht nur über Aspasia
als Denkerin, und hier ist ein letzter Grund,
warum Sie wegen des
Projekts als Ganzes nervös sein könnten, das habe ich
erwähnt  schon ein paar mal ist, dass ein
Großteil der Energie, die in den
letzten Jahren darauf verwendet wurde, Frauen zu studieren,
wirklich nicht der Antike
oder dem Mittelalter gewidmet wurde, sondern der
frühen Neuzeit, weil wir dort zahlreiche
Persönlichkeiten haben, von denen wir sicher sind  Ich
habe Werke wie Elizabeth von Böhmen,
Margaret Cavendish und Conway, das ist
eigentlich ein gutes Buch, das
ihre Werke jetzt alle in einem Band sammelt, und
das Spannende an diesen Frauen ist,
dass sie männlich waren
Gesprächspartner zum Beispiel als eine
Philosophie, die dem entspricht, was
sie über philosophische Themen denken, sie
sind sicherlich die Autoren der Werke
, von denen wir glauben, dass sie sie geschrieben haben, und die Werke
, die sie geschrieben haben, sind unbestreitbar
philosophisch, also gibt es einen Weg,
den Beitrag der Antike hervorzuheben
und  mittelalterliche Denker könnten
Ihnen irgendwie den Eindruck vermitteln, na ja, eigentlich gab es
in der gesamten Geschichte der
Philosophie nie ein Problem
in dem Sinne, dass es immer
Frauen gab, okay, Frauen waren nicht die dominierenden
Figuren in der Geschichte der Philosophie, die meisten
Philosophen waren Männer dort waren
philosophisch  Kontexte, wie ich schon sagte, in der
mittelalterlichen Universität, wo Frauen nicht
teilnehmen durften, aber trotzdem
gab es immer weibliche
Philosophen, und das könnte Sie auf die
Idee bringen, dass das keine große Sache ist, wenn wir in die
frühe Neuzeit kommen und wir diese wirklich
prominenten interessanten Persönlichkeiten haben und  Also ich
denke, das wäre ein Fehler, also was
ich sagen möchte, ist eigentlich
Etwas komplizierter als
das, was ich sagen würde, ist, dass die
Geschichte der Frauen in der Philosophie im
Allgemeinen zumindest in der europäischen Geschichte
eher so abläuft, dass es im
Grunde vier Phasen gibt, also haben wir in der ersten
Phase Texte, die
zwei Frauen sind  das widert Frauen wie Plato
und Aristoteles an und sie benutzen Frauen als
Sprecherinnen, aber wir können nicht
wirklich sicher sein, dass die
Darstellung der Frauen irgendetwas mit einer echten Frau zu tun hat,
die tatsächlich Ideen hatte
philosophische Ideen,
die in diesen Texten festgehalten werden und  Sie werden sehen,
was ich meine, wenn wir in dieser ersten
Vorlesung fortfahren, die übrigens auch für
den altindischen Kontext gilt, wie wir
später sehen werden, die nächste Phase ist die
Spätantike, wir haben noch keine Texte
, die tatsächlich sind  von Frauen, aber wir haben
Werke, die sehr überzeugend an bestimmte Frauen gebunden sind, von
denen wir guten Grund haben
zu glauben, dass sie philosophische
Interessen gehabt und einige
oder alle davon zum Ausdruck gebracht hätten  Die Ideen, die
ihnen in diesen Werken beschrieben werden, und
hier wäre ein gutes Beispiel Macrina, die
ich gerade erwähnt habe, also glaube ich persönlich, dass
auf der Grundlage dieses Textes, über den
wir sprechen werden, von Gregor von Nyssa,
dass seine Schwester interessiert war  in
Philosophie und war im Großen und Ganzen eine Art
Plate-Inistin, die an die
Unsterblichkeit der Seele glaubte. Die Dinge, die
wir sie später sagen sehen werden,
wären ein weiteres Beispiel von Monica
Agustíns Mutter, also haben wir hier eine
überzeugende Darstellung von
Philosophinnen im Text  von Männern geschrieben
haben, haben wir im Mittelalter wieder eine Art
Sprung nach vorn, aber es bringt uns nicht
ganz in die Situation der frühen
Neuzeit, wo wir
Philosophinnen haben, die den Männern mehr oder weniger ebenbürtig
sind  das Gefühl, dass
sie sich tatsächlich an
philosophischen Debatten beteiligen und
sogar von sehr prominenten Männern ernst genommen werden dürfen
, das passiert im Mittelalter nicht wirklich,
aber was
wir jetzt haben, sind zumindest Werke  von Frauen und wir können
mit Sicherheit sagen, dass die Werke
in einigen Fällen authentisch sind, ist etwas
komplizierter als das, wie wir
später sehen werden, also könnte es überhaupt sein, dass wir
seine Übersetzung eines Werks einer Frau haben  und
die Übersetzung wurde von einem Mann gemacht oder
vielleicht war der Mann da war ein Mann
beteiligt, der die Ideen tatsächlich niedergeschrieben hat,
aber im Grunde sind wir in einer viel
besseren Situation als in der
Spätantike, weil wir Werke von Frauen haben, die
den Unterschied zwischen den
Mittelalter und
Frühe Neuzeit ist, dass im
Mittelalter so ziemlich alle
Figuren, die man sich ansehen kann, nur
umstritten sind. II Philosophen
spannen den Grund für die Verwendung des Wortes
Denker wieder
hat ihre eigenen Werke geschrieben, sie sind definitiv
authentisch, und diese Werke sind sicherlich
philosophisch, und das ist Christine de
Pizan, wie ich bereits erwähnt habe, aber wir
werden sie erst ganz am
Ende dieser Vortragsreihe kennenlernen, was ich
will  Für den Rest dieser ersten
Vorlesung wollen wir über ein paar Texte aus der klassischen Antike sprechen,
und hier meine ich wirklich
authentische Weise, also ist dies eine lange, lange
Zeit her, wir gehen bis
ins sechste Jahrhundert v. Chr. zurück, oder vielleicht auch hier
sein, wie Sie gleich sehen werden, und dann
werde ich etwas über Plato sagen. Das
nächste Mal werde ich etwas mehr über
Platon und Aristoteles sagen und was sie
selbst über sie dachten, und wie
dieser erste Vortrag sein wird
Wenn wir über den Dialog von Plato sprechen, der Frauen Exen zuerst genannt hat, so
sage ich, gehen Sie den ganzen Weg zurück bis ins sechste
Jahrhundert v. Chr. Zu der Gruppe von Philosophen
und Mathematikern oder religiösen Gottheiten
, die sich um einen vorsokratischen
Philosophen Pythagoras versammelten, also haben Sie fast
Ich habe nur von Pythagoras gehört, wenn auch nur, weil Sie vom Satz des Pythagoras gehört haben
und vielleicht wissen, dass der
Pythagoräismus nicht nur eine Art philosophische
Bewegung war, die Spezialisierung
und Mathematik beinhaltet, obwohl es das
auch war  also eine Art religiöse Bewegung
Pythagoras selbst, der wirklich geheimnisumwoben ist.
Wir wissen nicht viel mit
Sicherheit über Pythagoras. Das meiste, was wir
haben, sind viele Legenden und Anekdoten
und Mythen über ihn, aber er hat angeblich
eine Menge davon niedergelegt  Regeln des guten
Benehmens, einschließlich religiöser Regeln,
Ernährungsregeln, wie
zum Beispiel, dass man keine Bohnen essen sollte, sogar darüber, was man
anziehen sollte, also gibt es viele
Vorschriften darüber, wie man
als Pythagoräer lebt, und man kann
es sich in gewisser Weise als fast vorstellen  wie ein
religiöser Kult, also waren einige der frühesten
Mitglieder seiner Gruppe, die Pythagoräer,
einschließlich einiger seiner Familienmitglieder,
Frauen, und wir kennen ihren Namen,
also schließen sie Theon ein, oh Melissa, ja,
und aufregenderweise gibt es eine Reihe von Briefen,
die uns überliefert wurden  Geschrieben
von diesen Frauen ist es sogar noch
spannender, als dass wir zwei Gruppen von
Buchstaben haben, die unabhängig voneinander zu uns kommen,
einer ist ein Satz von fünf
Buchstaben mit Ihnen von Pythagoräern
die als eine Art Gruppe erhalten blieben, und
das andere sind einige Schriften,
die an einem See aufbewahrt wurden. Der alte christliche
Autor nennt Tobias
so aufregend von diesen Pythagoräern, dass
wir mehrere Texte haben, die
uns heute erhalten geblieben sind, tatsächlich haben wir zwei Textsätze und
so weiter  Einerseits haben wir eine Gruppe
von fünf Briefen, die von
drei pythagoreischen Frauen Theano
Melissa und Mia geschrieben wurden, und diese werden
zusammen als eine Art Gruppe aufbewahrt, so dass sie
zusammen als Texteinheit reisen, so
dass das eine Textset das andere
Textset ist  sind drei Werke, die lustig sind in einem
christlichen Philosophen oder einem Theologen, der
wirklich Tobias aus der späten
Integration nennt, der viele
Dokumente aus der Antike in einer Art
Kampala-Tori-Werk sammelte und uns einige
Werke von jemandem in Parität ohne und das gibt
Damen und  gentlemen ist der name von
platos mutter,
also was uns hier präsentiert wird, sind
anscheinend ein paar werke von
platos mutter und dann gibt es noch ein
werk von einer anderen
und FEM-Tests, das ist also sehr spannend
und scheint tatsächlich zu verfälschen, was ich
gerade gesagt habe,
nämlich dass es keine Werke von Frauen
aus der Antike gibt, also haben wir hier nichts
weniger als Briefe von Pythagoras als
unmittelbare Begleiter, einschließlich
Mitglieder seiner eigenen Familie und Nr  weniger als die
Spielermutter, also ist das sehr aufregend,
wenn leider theologische Studien
dieser Werke darauf hindeuten, dass sie
mehrere Jahrhunderte nach dem
Leben dieser Menschen geschrieben worden sein müssen. Wenn
Sie also eine stilistische Analyse des Griechischen durchführen, ist
es einfach nicht glaubhaft, dass sie es
bereits waren  im 6.
Jahrhundert v. Chr. geschrieben wurden oder dass die Werke von correct
you and I wirklich von Prick Toni geschrieben wurden,
insbesondere der Satz von fünf Briefen
der pythagoräischen Frauen, jetzt
gibt es offensichtlich viel Raum für Debatten darüber,
wer diese Werke geschrieben hat, also
schließt nichts aus  Dass sie von Frauen geschrieben wurden
Ich habe sogar gesehen
, dass es versuchsweise darauf hindeutet, dass
sie später von Frauen geschrieben wurden, die
nach diesen Origi benannt wurden  nal pythagoräischen Frauen
, das ist also eine Möglichkeit, aber ich denke, die
sichere Schlussfolgerung hier ist, dass wir nicht
wissen, wer sie geschrieben hat, wofür sie da sind
, sind Texte, die von
jemandem, einem Mann oder einer Frau, geschrieben und dann
diesen pythagoreischen Frauen zugeschrieben wurden
Die Idee scheint zu sein, dass bekannt war,
dass Pythagoras mit Frauen mit
diesem und jenem Namen in Verbindung gebracht wurde, es ist bekannt, wie
Ton seine Mutter hieß, und dann, als sich
jemand hinsetzte, um ein Werk über weibliche Tugend zu schreiben,
was wir für
Tianas Schreiben finden  Über die Person, die sich
hingesetzt hat, um bei [ __ ] okay zu schreiben, ich werde am Anfang sagen,
dies ist wieder von Prigioni,
Sie können sich verschiedene Gründe dafür vorstellen
, vielleicht nur,
um die Arbeit zu bewerben, damit sie
interessanter erscheint, oder vielleicht soll der Leser sogar
glauben  zu verstehen, dass es sich um eine
Art fiktive Autorschaft handelt und dass wir wissen, dass
es nicht wirklich von Protein geschrieben wurde
, das einen
symbolischen Wert haben könnte, dass es angenommen wurde, dass
es angeblich auf jeden Fall von ihr geschrieben wurde
haben wir diese beiden
Sätze von Texten, die seinen Frauen jetzt zugeschrieben werden
, könnten Sie denken, da ich gerade gesagt habe, dass
wir nicht wissen, wer sie wirklich geschrieben hat,
könnten wir sie einfach vergessen und weitermachen,
aber ich denke, das wäre eine  Fehler,
weil wir
beim Lesen dieser Texte tatsächlich etwas sehr Interessantes gelernt haben,
was ich bereits
irgendwie angedeutet habe, und zwar, dass die
zu hinterfragenden Texte eine sehr spezifische
Art von weiblichem Spin oder Wert für sie haben, also
wie ich gerade sagte, weil sie funktionieren  von
prigioni Obwohl sie philosophischer sind
als die Texte, die den Pythagoräern zugeschrieben werden, die
Briefe schrieben,
konzentriert sich Virginia sehr stark auf die Idee der
weiblichen Tugend, etwas, das
in ihren Schriften, die übrigens kurz sind, häufig auftaucht
, äh eingefroren ist  Eine griechische
Tugend, die Mäßigkeit bedeutet, wurde
ich normalerweise übersetzt, und die Idee
wäre da, denn eine so eingefrorene
Mäßigkeit ist das charakteristische
Merkmal einer tugendhaften Frau, also wollen wir
das vielleicht in unseren Frauen  und was wir als
frauen aus
männlicher und weiblicher sicht betrachten wollen
noch deutlicher wird bei den briefen
von pythagoreischen frauen, dass wir
es hier mit spezifisch weiblichen themen zu tun haben,
denn die themen der fünf
briefe sind nicht gleich  Metaphysik oder
Ethik im Allgemeinen, also ist es nicht so
, als würde ich lesen, dass ich eine
Ethik über Aerosol oder Platons Republik machen werde,
es ist viel mehr wie das richtige Lesen von
Ratschlägen einer älteren Frau für eine andere Frau, die
Hilfe braucht, um ihren Haushalt zu führen
und so etwas  Beispiele wären,
wie sollten Sie Ihre Sklavinnen behandeln, wie
Sie Ihre Kinder erziehen sollten, sie nicht
zu viel ernähren, dafür sorgen, dass sie sich nicht
an Luxus und sanftes Leben gewöhnen
Ehemann
betrügt dich, also ist der Brief an
jemanden geschrieben, der sich darüber beschwert hat, dass ihr
Ehemann auf Abwege geraten ist, und deprimierenderweise
lautet der Ratschlag im Grunde, sei netter zu deinem
Ehemann, er wird die Herrin satt haben
e  Irgendwann und er wird zu Ihnen zurückkommen, wenn
Sie nett genug sind, also haben wir es hier nicht
gerade mit proto-feministischer Literatur zu
tun, und es ist
tatsächlich in mehrfacher Hinsicht nicht
feministisch, dass sie davon ausgeht, dass
Frauen etwas zu tun haben  Es
wird immer um die Führung des
Haushalts gehen, weil dies
in der antiken griechischen und auch in der römischen Gesellschaft als die Funktion der Frau angesehen wurde,
und dann
sogar innerhalb dessen die Ratschläge, die
den Empfängerinnen gegeben werden, vorausgesetzt, dass
die Empfänger dies wirklich tun sollen  Seien Sie
Frauen, der Rat, der gegeben wird, ist
in der Tat nicht sehr feministisch, wie ich gerade gegeben habe, wie
bei dem Beispiel, das ich gerade gegeben habe, wie Sie
damit umgehen können, dass Ihr Ehemann Sie
betrügt, oder wenn Sie daran denken,
Ratschläge zur Behandlung von Füßen zu geben, wie Sie
Sklavinnen behandeln  Im Haushalt geht es
hier offensichtlich nicht darum, die Befreiung der Frau zu sehen
oder zu sagen, dass Frauen
den Männern gleichgestellt sind, oder ähnliches,
im Gegenteil, es geht darum, zu zeigen, wie die
tugendhafte Frau ist  kann ihre Tugend nutzen,
um ihre Funktion am besten zu erfüllen, und ihre
Funktion ist es, den Haushalt zu führen, das ist
eine Idee, die sich durch die
Antike zieht, also zum Beispiel auch ein Peristyl bis
nächste Woche, er nimmt auch nur
an, dass die Funktion der Frau
in der Familie darin besteht  Der
Historiker Xenophon, der
auch ein Freund von Sokrates war und über den ich
in Kürze mehr
sagen werde, sagt an einer Stelle in einem
seiner Werke, dass das gut geführte Haus das
Haus ist, in dem die Taten der  Männer sind
den Taten der Frau gleich, weil
der Mann das Geld einbringt und die
Frau das Geld ausgibt und sie
müssen gleich sein und Sie bekommen offensichtlich Ärger,
wenn die Frau
mehr Geld ausgibt als der Mann macht, also
diese Vorstellung, dass Frauen sind  irgendwie an
das Haus gebunden kommt in
diesen pythagoräischen Buchstaben sehr stark zum Vorschein, und ich habe
hier ein Zitat von jemandem namens 8b
Whitson, der ein Buch über die
pythagoreischen Materialien von Frauen geschrieben hat
, sagt sie Texte zur
Haushaltsethik  selbst sind sehr oft geschlechtsspezifisch, das
heißt nicht nur die behandelten Themen
fallen in die Kategorien
männlich und weiblich, sondern auch die genannten
Angebote und oft sind die Empfänger männlich
oder weiblich entsprechend dem Geschlecht
der Inhalte.
Ich möchte nicht leugnen, dass diese
Werke philosophisch interessant sein können, und
tatsächlich denke ich, dass alles, was ich gerade gesagt habe, in gewisser Weise
philosophisch interessant ist,
weil es uns einen Einblick in ein
Problem gibt, das ich zuvor richtig erwähnt habe, und somit
einen Einblick in das, was die alten
Menschen dachten  Frauenphilosophie,
nämlich die Ideen, vielleicht Ideen darüber, wie
man Tugend ausübt, indem man ein gut geführtes
Haus führt, gelegentlich gibt es viel
robusteres philosophisches Material,
besonders in dem Material, das
von Stowe-Voreingenommenheit gesammelt wird, also ist eine der
Ideen, die man in diesen Werken bekommt, dass der
Brunnen  auf dem Haus ist parallel zum
Kosmos, was eine Idee ist, die sich
durch alle Richtungen zieht, also
gibt es tatsächlich eine Art Runnin  Eine Parallele dazu, dass
alte Philosophen gerne
zwischen dem Individuum oder der Seele,
dem Guten im Haus, dem Guten in der Stadt
und dem Kosmos als Ganzes ziehen, und so wäre die
Idee, dass man zum Beispiel in
jedem dieser Kontexte eine Art haben möchte
des Gleichgewichts oder der Harmonie zwischen den
verschiedenen Teilen mit einem führenden Teil
, der die Dinge von oben kontrolliert, also vermisse ich den
ganzen Grund, warum der rationale Teil
der Seele die Seele im Haus regieren würde, in dem
der Ehemann
alle Angelegenheiten regieren und irgendwie überwachen würde
der Haushalt sich vergewissern, dass die Sklaven das
tun, was sie tun sollen,
sich vergewissern, dass die Frau das tut, was
sie tun soll, die Frau dazu erziehen,
ihr zu helfen, das Haus zu führen, dann ähnlich wie in
der Stadt, die eine gut geführte Stadt hätte
König, der weiß, was er tut, es
könnte eine Königin sein, wie wir später in Plato sehen werden
Vernünftig,
wie die Seele und der Ehemann das
Haus und die Menschen regieren, soweit der Kosmos reicht,
wir haben Gott, der das gesamte Universum
vorsorglich regiert, also ist das eine Idee, die
man in diesen pythagoreischen Werken bekommt, und ich
würde sagen, das ist eine wirklich
philosophische Idee, die man gelegentlich bekommt
Ideen, die ausgeprägter
pythagoreisch sind, und Sie haben sich
vielleicht darüber gewundert, was das
alles mit dieser pythagoreischen ISM zu tun hat,
also bekommen Sie gelegentlich Material
in diesen Texten, das auf
Mathematik oder eine wirklich gute Beispielmusik
anspielt, so dass Pythagoräer berühmt sind  dafür
, dass du dich für Einheitsmusik interessierst und
einer der fünf Briefe darüber,
wie man sein Haus führt, wenn es
darum geht, wie man die Sklavin behandelt, sagt,
dass man nicht zu leicht zu ihr sein
sollte, noch sollte man zu hart zu ihr
sein  Behandeln Sie sie wie ein
Musikinstrument, indem Sie die Saiten nicht zu
fest oder zu locker machen, und das hat vielleicht
einen Moment, in dem Sie sehen, warum
diese Texte möglicherweise haben  Pythagoräischen Frauen zugeschrieben wurden,
sie sind nicht nur
berühmte Frauen, sondern Frauen, die
Namen von Frauen haben, ich denke, ich sollte sagen,
dass sie mit einer bestimmten Reihe
von philosophischen Themen verbunden sind, also hier ist
Musik, aber allgemeiner Tugend,
die alles ausbalanciert  auf
harmonische Weise zu laufen, und das ist wirklich die
Hauptidee, die aus diesen
pythagoreischen Werken hervorgeht, das ist es wirklich, und ich
würde sagen, dass die Werke als Ganzes, wenn
sie sich durch irgendetwas im
Allgemeinen auszeichnen, dann durch ihr Intro
in Harmonie in einem Kontext, der es tun würde
für Frauen von Interesse sein, also haben wir zumindest
vermeintlich Material, das von
Frauen und wahrscheinlich für Frauen über dieses
pythagoreische Team der Harmonie im
Kontext der weiblichen Sphäre geschrieben wird, was
genau das Haushalts-Okay ist, also gibt es
eine andere Sache, über die ich vorher sprechen möchte
diese Vorlesung ist vorbei, und das ist
Platon, wie ich schon sagte, beim nächsten Mal werden wir
uns damit befassen, was Platon
in seinen anderen Dialogen tut, wenn er
spricht  über Frauen und
insbesondere werden wir uns mit
der Republik befassen, aber ich wollte erwähnen,
dass es ein paar Dialoge von
Platon gibt, in denen er tatsächlich eine Frau zu einer
Hauptsprecherin in einem seiner Dialoge macht,
also falls Sie jemals einen haben  Hatte irgendein Plato, den Sie wissen,
dass Plato keine Abhandlungen schreibt, er
schreibt Dialoge, normalerweise ist die
Hauptfigur Sokrates, und Sokrates wird
gezeigt, wie er Gespräche mit anderen
Leuten führt, damit er sie fragen könnte, was Tugend
ist, was sie sagen und was sie für Tugend halten,
und er sagt es gut  das ist eine
interessante Idee und dann widerlegt er
sie, das ist eine Art typischer, besonders
früher sokratischer Dialog. Ich spiele sie jetzt.
Das ist nicht immer der Fall, also gibt es
einige Dialoge, bei denen wir anstelle
einer Art Hin- und Her-Argumentation
etwas mehr bekommen  wie Reden
vielleicht sogar eine ganze Reihe von Reden
und bei weitem der berühmteste Fall einer
weiblichen Sprecherin in einem antiken
philosophischen Werk ist in Platons
Symposium, also Platons Symposium, das ich nicht verstehe.  Ich
habe keine Zeit, Ihnen die ganze Geschichte
des Dialogs zu erzählen, aber im Grunde handelt es sich um eine Reihe
von Reden verschiedener Charaktere,
die bei einer Trinkparty anwesend sind,
was Symposium bedeutet, also bedeutet ein Teil von Posey nur
, Taten zu trinken, bedeutet zusammen und
Trinken, also bedeutet es eine Trinkparty
und sie sind sich einig, dass diese Leute
bei dieser Trinkparty anwesend waren, die alle Männer waren, weil
sie vereinbart hatten, dass jeder von
ihnen eine Rede zu Ehren des Liebeseros halten würde,
also gehen sie nacheinander weiter,
einer der Redner ist bei dem
Gedichtdichter Aristophanes und  dann,
wenn Sokrates an der Reihe ist, hält er seine
Rede, aber Sokrates hält
normalerweise keine Reden, also erzählt er
stattdessen eine Geschichte darüber, wie
er in den Künsten der Liebe ausgebildet wurde oder wirklich
die Bedeutung der Liebe, vielleicht von einem
Philosophen, dessen Name lautete  Gottheit MA und
sie ist eine Frau, also spricht sie darüber, dass
Liebe wirklich eine Art treibende Kraft ist
, die uns dazu bringt, nach Schönheit zu suchen, und die
meisten Menschen suchen oft nach Schönheit und
physischem Kontext  im Zusammenhang mit dem
Versuch, Sex zu haben, aber es gibt eine
erhabenere Art, Schönheit zu sehen, die
Philosophie ist, und letztendlich
wollen wir die Form der Schönheit begreifen, also haben wir
eine Art ausgewachsenen Platonismus, und
dies ist ein sehr berühmtes Werk und so weiter
viele Diskussionen darüber, ob die liebe
Tina eine reale Person ist, also haben
wir leider keine anderen externen
Beweise. Der Dialog darüber, ob
Gottheit wirklich existiert hat, mag
unglaublich erscheinen, dass diese sehr
beeindruckende Philosophin, die Sokrates lehrte,
ohne unsere existiert haben könnte  Wir
wissen es aus keiner anderen Quelle, aber seien wir
ehrlich, es gibt eine Menge, die wir
über die Antike nicht wissen. Warum gibt es also nicht auch
einige Details im Dialog, die
darauf hindeuten, dass Plato eine ziemlich
bestimmte Person im Sinn hat, also gibt es
einige Details über die Gottheit Emma  Leben
, die nicht wirklich so klingen, als hätte Platon
sie einfach aus einem ganzen
Stoff gemacht, und so denken viele Leute, dass ein
Team, das eine echte Person gewesen sein könnte,
eigentlich pr bin  Ich wollte das auch glauben,
aber ich wäre ziemlich nervös, wenn ich
einfach einer
echten historischen Person namens Gottheit
ma zuschreiben würde,
was Platon hat  hat
sie in verschiedenen Dialogen gesagt,
ob es Sophos wie Protagoras und
Gordias oder Sokrates selbst oder andere
Philosophen wie Parmenides sind. Ich
denke wirklich, wir sollten sehr nervös sein, wenn wir davon
ausgehen, dass Platon sich hinsetzen würde,
um ein Diol zu schreiben,
und genau richtig, wie die Art von Bericht
darüber ist  was eine andere Person dachte Ich
denke, Platon war ein viel zu
interessanter Philosoph, um das zu tun, und
deshalb bin ich irgendwie agnostisch, was
dies uns über die Bedeutung der Gottheit sagt, wenn sie wirklich
existiert, gibt es jedoch einen anderen
Dialog, der noch stärker dominiert wird
eine frau als das symposium ist dies
imposant war eigentlich ein sehr langer
dialog und obwohl die gottheit
die kulminierende rede verpasst erreicht es  viel
weniger als die Hälfte des
Dialogs, aber es gibt einen anderen Dialog,
den niemand jemals liest, genannt Min
Exynos. Es ist sehr kurz, es ist überhaupt kein
richtiger Dialog.
Was passiert, ist, dass Sokrates
auf einen anderen Charakter namens
Nexen trifft und dann rezitiert  Bilden Sie einen Exodus
eine Rede, die ihm von
jemandem namens Aspasia im Maximus beigebracht wurde. Die
Hauptrednerin ist tatsächlich für einen
Spazio da, also ist sie die Person,
die Sokrates die Rede beigebracht hat. Es ist eine
Trauerrede für die gefallenen Soldaten von Athen,
und hier halten wir  Ich habe das Gedicht nicht
, das wir mit der Gottheit MA hatten, denn als
Fozzie war es definitiv eine echte Person, die
sie sehr stark mit
jemandem in Verbindung gebracht hat, der vor Platon lebte, nämlich
Perikles
, der eine Zeit lang der Anführer von Athen war
und Aspasia gewesen sein soll  seine
Geliebte gibt es eine großartige Geschichte, die meiner
Meinung nach viel über die alten
Einstellungen zur Ehe und zu Frauen verrät, also
gibt es ein paar Quellen, die uns sagen,
wie viel  h Perikles liebte Aspasia, und der
Beweis dafür ist, dass
er sie jeden Morgen auf dem Weg aus dem Haus
küsste und sie dann
abends, wenn er nach Hause kam, einen Haufen küsste,
aber es war wirklich irgendwie ausschweifend, dass er
nicht treten sollte  und uns zeigen, wie sehr er sie
liebte, sie war anscheinend auch
Rhetoriklehrerin, es gibt auch
irgendwelche furchtlosen Gerüchte über ihr Leben,
dass sie irgendwie mit Prostituierten gearbeitet hat
oder ein Zuhälter war,
aber ich denke, wir können einfach davon ausgehen,
dass das so ist  von bösen Gerüchten, die
mächtige Frauen immer angezogen haben und
dass der konservative Perikles
sicherlich von seinen Feinden angezogen hätte, also
wissen wir, dass es eine Würze gibt, und wir
haben auch andere Beweise über sie, also
taucht sie in Santa Fong auf, zum Beispiel der
Historiker, der ein Mitarbeiter war  von
Sokrates, wie ich bereits erwähnt habe, und
es gibt tatsächlich eine wirklich schöne Geschichte
über Aspasia, die im
berühmten römischen Redner und Anwalt
Cicero aufbewahrt wird, also versucht Cicero, uns ein e zu geben  Beispiel
für etwas anderes, aber sie er
erzählt uns diese Geschichte aus der Arbeit von jemandem
in s Kingis, der ein Anhänger von
Sokrates war, und es ist eine Geschichte über einen Spazio
, der mit Xenophon, diesem Historiker, spricht, also heißt
es dies in einem Werk von s kameez, dem
sokratischen Sokrates  erzählt uns, dass eine Spionin
Xena das folgende Gespräch mit
Xenophons Frau hatte und von sich aus sagte,
bitte sag mir Frau von Xenophon, wenn deine
Nachbarin ein besseres Stück
Goldschmuck hätte als du, würdest du
ihre oder deine bevorzugen, antwortete Liz Xenophons
Frau, was wäre, wenn sie  Hätten Sie bessere Kleidung und
andere Frauenputze, die Sie hätten, würden
Sie Ihre oder ihre bevorzugen,
also ist hier die nächste Frage. Befriedigen Sie Xia.
Was wäre, wenn sie einen besseren Ehemann hätte als
Sie, würden Sie Ihren Ehemann oder sie bevorzugen,
wenn die Frau dann wegen dieser Aspasia erröten würde
fing an, mit Xenophon selbst zu sprechen,
und sie stellte ihm die gleichen Fragen, aber
beachten Sie, dass sie ihn nach einem
besseren Pferd oder einer besseren Farm fragte, also sind die Beispiele
geschlechtsspezifisch und die  Wenn ich es nicht
sagen konnte, verstummt auch er und Aspasia
fährt fort, da Sie beide
mir nicht die eine Antwort gegeben haben, die ich hören wollte,
werde ich für mich selbst sagen, was jeder von
Ihnen über Ihre Frau denkt
den besten Ehemann zu haben, und du Xenophon willst
mehr als alles andere die beste
Frau haben, also wenn ihr beide es nicht schaffen könnt,
dass es keinen besseren Mann oder keine
bessere Frau auf der Welt gibt, dann wird
euch immer viel mehr fehlen als an
allem was  Sie denken am besten,
dass Sie Xenophon der Ehemann der
bestmöglichen Frau sein sollten und dass sie
mit dem bestmöglichen Mann verheiratet wäre, okay, also
was können wir aus diesem kleinen Text entnehmen, ein
Teil davon ist nur die Gewürze,
die in die Art von gegossen werden  Sokrates mag eine Rolle
von einem Mageren, also erinnern Sie sich, dass
Skinnys jemand ist, der mit Sokrates herumhing
und Werke im Stil eines
frühen sokratischen Dialogs schrieb, und in diesem verlorenen
Dialog, der Aspasia gewidmet war,
verachtet er anscheinend eine Art von
Sokrates-Like  Bild
Xenophon erwähnt
sie auf die gleiche Art und Weise, indem er moralische Weisheit spendet und Menschen peinlich macht, und er
zeigt ihr zum Beispiel an einer Stelle, wie sie
Ratschläge zum Matchmaking gibt, so dass andere
eine Ehe gründen. Ich denke, es ist
sehr aufschlussreich, dass ein Spazio in diesen Fällen
Kontexte ist nicht nur eine Art generische
philosophische Frau, sie
wird als jemand präsentiert, der den
Menschen speziell etwas über die richtige Ehe zu sagen hat
Matchmaking Die
beste Frau zu sein, die man sein könnte, der beste Ehemann zu sein, der
man sein kann, also meine Art von Gefühl
für den Weg  Dass ein Spazio
in diesem Kreis von Sokrates verwendet wird, ist, dass sie eine
berühmte Frau ist. Sie ist berühmt für ihre Rhetorik.
Sie wird auch für ihren politischen
Scharfsinn und ihre Intelligenz im
Allgemeinen gelobt, aber wenn sie sie irgendwie zitieren,
stellen sie sie als Ideenquelle dar,
was sie tun  Sie geben ihr als
Sprecherin wieder Recht über diese Art von
Frauenthemen, also über Angelegenheiten der
Haushaltsehe, wenn ich
sie in Exodus ansehe, was ich bin  Neugierig ist,
ob Plato das Gleiche tun wird, und
Sie könnten denken, offensichtlich nicht so.
Hier ist, wie der
Dialog mit diesem anderen Typen auf dem Nexus aussieht,
und dann rezitiert er eine Diode, die
eine Rede rezitiert, die er
lernen sollte  von einem Spa und sagt sogar,
dass sie ihn schlagen würde, wenn er
die Rede nicht richtig lernen würde, damit er sie auswendig lernen kann,
und die Rede ist zu Ehren der
Kriegsschuld Athens, also denken Sie
gut nach  Was könnte ein weniger weiblicher Kontext sein,
als über die geretteten gefallenen Soldaten zu sprechen,
und meine Antwort auf diese Frage lautet
, wenn Sie sich die Wählscheibe
etwas genauer ansehen, werden Sie feststellen, dass
es eine Art Thema gibt, das sich
durch die ganze Sache zieht  Das ist im
Grunde das Thema, von dem man erwarten würde, dass Plato
es einer Rednerin in den Mund legt,
nämlich die Familie, und der Grund, warum
dieses Thema so stark durchdringt,
ist, dass sie eine ihrer Hauptideen in
der Rede ist, dass Athen ist und sogar
die la  Und dass Athen bebaut ist, ist
wie der Elternteil der Soldaten, also
hier ist zum Beispiel eine Passage von Anfang an
im Dialog, in der es heißt, jetzt liegen die gefallenen
gefallenen Soldaten im Tod an den
vertrauten Orten ihrer Mutter, die sie
geboren hat, säuge sie und empfange sie  Als
ihre eigene wird sie sicherlich zuerst nur
die Mutter selbst feiern und später wird
erwähnt, dass es die Kinder des Landes Athen waren, die dies taten, als die
Athener die Perser in dem berühmten Krieg
gegen die einfallenden persischen Armeen besiegten
, und es gibt eine Menge  von
anderen Textbeweisen in ihnen in
Exodus kennzeichnet Aspasia als jemanden,
der besonders etwas zu der Idee zu sagen hat,
dass Athen als Stadt
eine tugendhafte Stadt ist, gerade weil es
eine Familie ist, also hatte ich über die Theorie,
sie in Exodus zu haben  und die Theorie ist nicht,
dass oh, das ist nur eine Rede, die
Aspasia tatsächlich für eine echte
Beerdigung geschrieben hat. Meine Theorie ist, dass Plato das
tat, was er oft tut, nämlich
eine berühmte Person zu imitieren a  Und auch irgendwie
zu zeigen, dass er seine eigene hochrhetorische Rede erfinden konnte, eine
politisch
aufgeladene Rede zum Lob Athens. Manche
Leute denken, es ist eine Parodie, manche Leute
denken, es ist ernst
Der Grund, warum er besonders als Redner so positiv ausgewählt wurde,
ist, dass er
eine Rede schreiben wollte, die die
Idee der Stadt als Familie und einer
tugendhaften Stadt als einer Art Familieneinheit hervorhebt
und die tatsächlich an etwas
anknüpft, zu dem wir gehen werden  sehen Sie im nächsten
Vortrag, denn wie wir Sie beim nächsten
Mal sehen, denkt auch Plato und wir sehen dies
in seiner Republik, dass die tugendhafte Stadt
oder die zu Recht falsche Stadt eine ist, in der sich
die Soldaten der Stadt als
eine Familie betrachteten
so  Seine Idee, dass die Familieneinheit
irgendwie zur Stadt oder
zumindest zum militärischen Teil der Stadt aufgeblasen werden könnte,
ist ein zutiefst platonisches Thema, von dem wir
von der Republik erfahren,
vielleicht tauchte es hier in t auf  he men
Exodus und dass Plato eine
weibliche Gesprächspartnerin gewählt hat, um
diesen Punkt zu verdeutlichen, und wenn Sie Zweifel haben,
ob Platon
über die Tatsache nachgedacht hätte, dass ein Spazio eine Frau war,
dann würde ich Sie auf das Ende des verweisen
Dialog, weil ganz am Ende, nachdem
Sokrates die Rede rezitiert hat,
Platon Exynos gesagt hat, du bist
Aspasia, hast Glück, wenn eine Frau, obwohl sie es
ist, solche Reden verfassen kann,
also ist es offensichtlich in Platos Gedanken, dass er
eine Frau verachtet, während er schreibt  den
Dialog und er hat sich sogar entschieden,
diese Tatsache auf der allerletzten Seite hervorzuheben,
also denke ich, was wir aus diesem Beispiel gelernt haben,
und ich könnte auch anderen
Beispielen geben. Ich habe bereits das
Beispiel der Briefe von pythagoräischen
Frauen gegeben, die wir sind  Übrigens werden wir etwas Ähnliches sehen
, wenn wir ins alte Indien kommen,
wo wir aus all diesen Beispielen lernen,
dass wir sehr
vorsichtig sein müssen, wenn wir uns Darstellungen von
Frauen in antiken Texten nähern, und ich denke, das
könnte zutreffen  Texte aus
allen Epochen trifft meines Erachtens besonders auf
antike Texte zu, weil in der Antike von
Frauen wirklich erwartet wurde, dass sie sich sehr
stark an bestimmte Geschlechternormen halten, und
was wir gelernt haben, ist, dass wir
die Existenz von weiblichen
Denkern und diesen verschiedenen nicht ausschließen können  Sehr früh
tauchen meist Texte auf, die
auf die Existenz solcher Denker hinweisen und
vielleicht sogar
Denker als eine Art Sprecher kooptieren und ihnen
dann Ideen in den Mund nehmen, die
Männer mit Frauen assoziieren oder die Männer vermitteln
wollen  vielleicht an eine Leserschaft weiblicher Schriftsteller,
also
möchten sie zum Beispiel etwas darüber sagen, wie eine
tugendhafte Frau ist, sie
möchten vielleicht etwas darüber sagen, wie ein
tugendhafter Haushalt ist, sie
möchten vielleicht sogar etwas darüber sagen
, was eine  tugendhafte Stadt ist
wie Erinnern Sie sich an das, was ich zuvor über
die Parallele zwischen dem Haushalt und
der Stadt gesagt habe, also diese Idee, dass die Harmonie
die Harmonisierte Gesellschaft ist  al Gruppe des
Haushalts die Stadt die Idee, dass
dies wie eine Familie sein könnte, die mit sich
selbst harmoniert, auf die harmonische Weise
, die in der Antike eine sehr geschlechtsspezifische Vorstellung
war, und wir können dies daran erkennen
, dass diese Vorstellung oft mit dem Begriff „
weiblich“ vorgebracht wird  Sprecher kann es
sogar sein, dass es sich bei einigen der von uns
betrachteten Fälle wie diesen Briefen,
die den pythagoräischen Frauen zugeschrieben werden
, tatsächlich um Frauen handelt, und
das möchte ich nicht ausschließen, und
es ist natürlich genauso gut möglich  Für eine Frau ist
es geschlechtsspezifisch, wenn sie an ein bestimmtes Thema denkt,
wie für einen Mann,
dass es geschlechtsspezifisch ist, und
ich möchte wirklich nur sagen, dass wir
aus diesen antiken Texten etwas über Frauen und Philosophie lernen, aber
vielleicht  Wir lernen nicht so sehr etwas über
bestimmte Frauen aus der Antike, sondern darüber, was
die Leute dachten, worüber Frauen nachdenken sollten,
wenn sie Philosophie machen.
Okay, das war es für diese erste Vorlesung
Ich werde das nächste Mal über Platon
und Aristoteles und ihre Ansichten über
Frauen und ihren Platz in der Gesellschaft sprechen